We know about Donald Trump's endless golfing right we've talked about Donald Trump golfing a lot at his own
Golf clubs and part of it is that Trump by golfing at his own
Golf clubs so frequently is funneling taxpayer money into his own businesses. That's one issue but with Trump
There's always some double standard or hypocrisy and you might remember that Donald Trump would slam Obama
relentlessly when when President Obama was president for golfing a little bit and
Donald Trump is golfing more than any president in the history of the United States
And the golfing is becoming such an obsession such a distraction really that Trump's golfing is now
Interfering with his duties as president of the United States
And you are paying for Donald Trump's golf you're paying for Trump's travel to the golf courses
Your money is being fun... yours and mine by the way. I'm not exempt from this. I'm just as
impacted by this as you are your money is being funneled
into Donald Trump's resorts because of the entire apparatus that travels with him that is booking rooms and
renting golf carts every time Trump goes goes golfing.
But it is now taking Trump's attention away from being
President you can make the argument that that's a good thing right if you believe that the less Trump does the better off we are,
That's an argument you can make: "We want Trump not doing president stuff," but he's still raping and pillaging
taxpayer money to play golf and we should all be against that, particularly you would imagine
a fiscal conservative, so-called fiscal conservatives.
102 days
Donald trump has now spent on the golf course during his first ten months as president
Donald trump tweeted and the White House claimed during
Thanksgiving that Donald Trump would be working on job creation and other very important issues during the holiday
Turns out that he basically played golf the entire Thanksgiving vacation
And he also broke another promise which was that while he was president Trump told us his company isn't going to be working with foreign
entities part of Donald Trump's vacation was spent
Surrounding the work going on with Trump world golf club, Dubai
Which is now under development in as the name suggests...
Dubai
Another broken promise from the campaign and Donald Trump also sending
Unhinged tweets during the Thanksgiving holiday. You'll recall that
for comparison
President Obama last Thanksgiving went to work at a retirement home for
Military veterans last year he did something similar in 2015
He worked at a soup kitchen in 2014 George W. Bush was also known for some volunteering on national holidays
Meanwhile Donald Trump is golfing and sending angry tweets while development of his foreign
golf course continues. And forget about how progressives interpret this chicanery of
Publishing a busy schedule and then ending up just golfing. How can anyone on the right defend this? I am I...
Every time we do a story like this I ask for someone on the right who believes that this is ok or a good thing
Get in touch with me explain to me how you defend this. Explain to me how this fits into the idea of personal responsibility,
the idea of hard work, the idea of working for the little guy. None of it is happening
Absolutely none of it is happening under Trump because he's the epitome of the
Man who should never be a public servant because he thinks that the public is there to serve him not the other way around
and again
The only silver lining I can think of here is that we really don't want Trump
Dismantling society in government, and if he's playing golf presumably
It's a break from destroying our country and the fact that
Taxpayers are paying for it is the problem. The fact that it's a it's another one of these horrible double standards from Trump is
part of the problem. The fact that Trump lied
endlessly about he would never really leave the White House and wouldn't have time to play golf because he'd have so much to do
That's the problem
And we also have to realize that the destruction and the dismantling of the US
will continue even with Trump when Trump is golfing because whether Trump is golfing or not
Ajit Pai is going to continue trying to repeal net neutrality
someone that Trump appointed. Whether Trump is cheating on the golf course and... and...
Trimming the number of strokes required to get those non-existent hole-in-ones reminds... reminds me of a Kim Jong Un
uh.. or uh.. Kim Jong Il rather, and his golf lies.
Whatever Trump is doing whether he's in the Oval Office or on the golf course Scott Pruett at the EPA is taking that
agency apart and that is why you need to vote in every
Single election and we'll be talking
About Roy Moore's special election on December 12 and starting to gear up for the midterms very very soon that is the solution
Hoping Trump golf so he doesn't do president stuff
It's not gonna work because the people he's appointed are still going to get things done.
We'll take a break back with more right after this.